[Música]
América Latina celebra la victoria de
Lula da Silva en las elecciones de
Brasil más de un día después de
conocerse los resultados el presidente
Yair bolsonaro sigue sin pronunciarse
insatisfecho sus Seguidores del sector
camionero han generado decenas de
bloqueos
Gustavo Petro y Nicolás Maduro se
reunirán Este martes en Caracas será el
primer encuentro entre los líderes de
Colombia y Venezuela en seis años y se
espera que entre otros temas profundicen
en el restablecimiento de su relaciones
lanza advertencia a las compañías
petroleras el mandatario les pidió
aumentar su producción nacional para
combatir el alza de los precios de la
gasolina de lo contrario impondrá un
impuesto a sus ganancias inesperadas
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil donde más de un día después de
conocerse la victoria del expresidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el presidente
Yair bolsonaro sigue guardando silencio
Se espera que se pronuncie Durante las
próximas horas mientras sus aliados lo
presionan para que reconozca su derrota
Lula obtuvo este domingo un 50,9% de los
votos frente al 49,1% de bolsonaro
insatisfechos ante los resultados
camioneros bolsonaristas han realizado
decenas de bloqueos en las carreteras de
todo el país previamente hablamos con
Óscar villena profesor en derecho
constitucional a quien le preguntamos
Cómo interpretar la reacción de El señor
bolsonar
bueno vos sonaro es un populista de
extrema derecha que hay tiene una
postura muy antes institucional durante
todos los cuatro años de gobierno Por
tanto la su no reconocimiento de los
resultados de decisión no llega a
suspender lo importante es que todos los
otros sectores relevantes de las
instituciones brasileñas a inicio de los
tribunales pero también los presidente
de la cámara de diputados senado Federal
han reconocido e inclusive su
vicepresidente que es un general
reformado también ha reconocido por
tanto es simple desmiente bolsonaro
desempeñando su rol como un populista
que no ha a que no nos gusta las
instituciones seguimos en la política de
las regiones Este martes el presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro se reunirá con
su homólogo Nicolás futuro en la capital
venezolana Caracas dos meses después del
restablecimiento de las relaciones
diplomáticas entre ambos países la
agenda del encuentro deberá enfocarse en
temas como su relación bilateral la
reapertura de sus fronteras y el
reingreso de Venezuela al sistema
interamericano de Derechos Humanos hacía
seis años que un dirigente colombiano no
había visitado a su vecino venezolano al
mismo tiempo maduro ahora vuelve a
acercarse a Brasil con el regreso de su
antigua Aliado el ex presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva más temprano
hablamos con nuestra corresponsal
Daniela Zambrano en Caracas quien nos
comentó si Nicolás Maduro también salió
fortalecido tras el triunfo del partido
de los trabajadores
sin duda recordemos que el presidente
Yahir bolsonario no tenía buenas
relaciones con Nicolás Maduro de hecho
fue uno de los presidentes de América
Latina que reconoció a Juan guaidó como
presidente interino y A pocas horas de
que Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva resultará
electo en Brasil ya Nicolás Maduro a
través de Twitter anunció que sostuvo
una conversación telefónica con Lula da
Silva decía a través de Twitter sostuvo
una buena conversación telefónica con el
presidente acordamos retomar la agenda
binacional de cooperación entre ambos
países así Nicolás Maduro gana un Aliado
más luego de que también en Colombia
cambiar a radicalmente la postura con
Venezuela puesto no tenía buenas
relaciones con el presidente Duque
también vale la pena destacar que
Venezuela Brasil es también uno de los
países que ha recibido la mayor cantidad
de venezolanos que han huido
prácticamente de Venezuela y de la
crisis económica sin duda es un
acercamiento que no se tenía con el
presidente Yahir bolsonaro también se ha
pronunciado el vicepresidente del
partido socialista Unido de Venezuela
diosdado cabello
hablaba sobre una posible Cumbre entre
Gustavo Petro y Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva y Nicolás Maduro que ahora había
un acercamiento entre ambos países que
antes no era posible en Estados Unidos
las autoridades imputaron cargos
federales al atacante de Paul pelos y el
esposo de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi el hombre de
42 años que irrumpió en la residencia de
los pelos y en San Francisco fue
imputado con cargos de agresión a un
familiar inmediato de un funcionario
estadounidense e intento de secuestro de
un funcionario estadounidense las
autoridades indicaron que la verdadera
intención del hombre que atacó a Paul
velozzi con un martillo era romperle las
rótulas a la líder demócrata los cargos
podrían conllevar penas de hasta 30 años
de cárcel
el acusado subió el el piso de la casa y
localizó el señor pelusí en su cama
durmiendo lo despertó y lo confrontó
sobre el paradero de la presidenta
peluci
se vio obligado a levantarse de la cama
en algún momento Durante este encuentro
pero sí intentó Acceder al ascensor de
la casa que tiene un teléfono el acusado
luego bloqueó el acceso al señor pelosi
a ese ascensor fue en algún momento
después de que el señor pelosi pidió ir
al baño que es donde pudo Llamar al 911
desde su teléfono celular
seguimos en Estados Unidos donde el
presidente Joe biden intenta bajar los
costos de los combustibles que afectan
directamente a los ciudadanos sobre todo
en un momento en el que los precios
están disparados y Los gigantes
petroleros estadounidenses reportan
ganancias multimillonarias la medida de
baile llega Justo a casi una semana de
las elecciones de medio término y en las
que los datos inflacionarios pueden
mover a los votantes Andrés granadillo
nos cuenta más
una cifra de ganancias
récord llegó al presidente Joe biden a
criticar a las petroleras y pedirles que
detengan las ganancias de guerra
refiriéndose al conflicto en Ucrania
no han cumplido su compromiso de
invertir en Estados Unidos de apoyar al
pueblo estadounidense una por una las
principales compañías petroleras han
reportado ganancias récord no solo un
rendimiento justo por el trabajo duro
todas las empresas tienen derecho a eso
pero me refiero a beneficios tan altos
que es difícil de creer
además les pidió aumentar la producción
en caso de no cumplir instalar el
congreso a imponer impuestos la idea de
bailén es mitigar los elevados precios
de la gasolina que afectan el bolsillo
de los estadounidenses a principios de
Julio pagaban unos 4,80 dólares en
promedio por un galón de gasolina normal
aunque los precios han bajado a unos
3,76 dólares de media a nivel nacional
pero la Casa Blanca afirma que deberían
ser más bajos dado el descenso de los
precios mundiales del petróleo en el
mismo periodo los gigantes mundiales de
la energía registraron enormes
beneficios trimestrales Epson móvil tuvo
ganancias de 20.000 millones de dólares
mientras Chevron de 11.200 millones
estas ganancias se deben al incremento
del precio del gas natural y de los
combustibles que inciden en el aumento
de la inflación a nivel mundial subir
los impuestos en Estados Unidos para las
grandes petroleras no tendrá un camino
fácil en el congreso menos aportas de
las legislativas de medio término donde
la buena salud de la economía ha estado
en la mirada de los electores
por cuarto día consecutivo los médicos
argentinos protagonizaron marchas Para
demandar aumentos salariales les
contesto parece lejos de terminar dado
que las autoridades hicieron un
ofrecimiento muy por debajo de las
aspiraciones de los manifestantes que
indicaron que han convocado a nuevas
movilizaciones y asambleas para los
próximos días Ramiro Cuevas nos cuenta
más en el siguiente informe
la protesta de los médicos de la ciudad
de Buenos Aires continúa por cuarto día
consecutivo Este martes interrumpieron
más de una docena de puntos vitales para
el tránsito Porteño y se dirigieron
nuevamente hacia el Ministerio de salud
de la ciudad la razón del paro Un
aumento salarial considerable la
situación particular
Argentina con tanta inflación y en
realidad de manera mundial con los
conflictos actuales que hay hacen que
cada vez sea peor la situación a pesar
de haber pasado un periodo como la
pandemia donde se supone que éramos
esenciales sentimos más
abandono todavía porque no no Se generó
ningún tipo de esos reconocimientos que
se nos vienen llegando de manera
histórica
las limitadas condiciones laborales de
los médicos y su poca remuneración
genera que la cantidad de profesionales
disminuya progresivamente
vemos con mucha preocupación el hecho de
que este año muy pocos cupos de
residentes y concurrentes fueron
ocupados históricamente siempre se
llenaban la lista de los hospitales y
Esto va a derivar en que se vayan
formando cada vez menos profesionales de
la salud y obviamente va a repercutir en
una crisis sanitaria a futuro porque
estamos viendo como cada vez menos
compañeros eligen formarse como
especialistas por nuestras condiciones
de trabajo el equipo del jefe de
gobierno Horacio Rodríguez larreta
ofreció 165 mil pesos una cifra por
debajo del monto de la canasta básica y
lejana a los 250 mil pesos que exigen
los manifestantes hasta que este
informativo Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]